>>> >>> THE GRANDSON OF THE LATE
PRINCE PHILIP IS SHOWING GRIEF
AT HIS PASSING.
HE PAID TRIBUTE TO HIS
GRANDFATHER SAYING HE IS
GRATEFUL FOR THE TIME HE AND HIS
FAMILY WERE ABLE SPEND WITH HIM.
PRINCE HARRY SHARED A SIMILAR
MESSAGE SAYING HE AND HIS WIFE
AND CHILDREN WILL ALWAYS HOLD A
SPECIAL PLACE FOR HIM IN THEIR
HEARTS.
>>> OVER THE WEEK, MOURNERS LEFT
FLOWERS AND CARDS TO HONOR
PRINCE PHILIP AND RIGHT NOW TOP
LAWMAKERS IN THE UK ARE
REMEMBERING THE DUKE.
EARLIER, THEY SHOWED A MOMENT OF
SILENCE IN HIS HONOR.
>> I BEG TO MOVE FOR THE HUMBLE
ADDRESS TO BE PRESENTED TO HER
MAJESTY EXPRESSING THE DEEPEST
SYMPATHIES IN THIS HOUSE FOR THE
DEATH OF THE ROYAL HIGHNESS, THE
DUKE OF EDINBOROUGH AND THE
HEART FELT THANKS IN THIS HOUSE
AND THIS NATION, HIS DEDICATION
TO THIS COUNTRY AND THE
COMMO
COMMONWEALTH.
>> THE HOUSE OF COMMONS PAID
TRIBUTE ABOUT A HALF AN HOUR
AGO, RECOGNIZING HIS MANY YEARS
OF SERVICE TO THE COUNTRY.
TAKE A LISTEN TO WHAT THE
BRITISH PRIME MINISTER HAD TO
SAY.
FOR MORE ON ALL OF THIS,
OBVIOUSLY, WE ARE JUST LISTENING
TO THE PRIME MINISTER THERE
PAYING TRIBUTE.
THE HOUSE OF COMMON SENSE ARE
GOING TO SPEND THE DAY PAYING
TRIBUTE AND HONORING PRINCE
PHILIP'S LEGACY.
ALSO, WE'VE HEARD FROM PRINCE
WILLIAM AND PRINCE HARRY
SPEAKING ABOUT THEIR
GRANDFATHER, WHAT DID THEY HAVE
TO SAY?
>> Reporter: ABSOLUTELY.
LOOK, LINDA, IT IS A WEEK OF
TRIBUTES FROM ALL CORNERS OF THE
KINGDOM AND REALLY FROM ALL
WALKS OF LIFE AND FROM EVERYONE.
SOW HEARD THE POLITICIANS AND
YOU HEARD THE PRIME MINISTER
LEADING BOTH HOUSES OF
PARLIAMENT IN TRIBUTE TO HIS
ROYAL HIGHNESS, THE LATE DUKE OF
EDINBOROUGH, SINCE FRIDAY, WE
HAVE GRADUALLY HEARD FROM AN
INCREASING NUMBER OF FAMILY
MEMBERS.
IT WAS THE QUEEN, WHO DIRECTLY
WAS CITED BY PRINCE ANDREW THE
PASSING OF HER HUSBAND LEFT A
HUGE VOID IN HER LIFE.
ON SATURDAY, WE HEARD FROM THE
HEIR TO THE THRONE, PRINCE
CHARLES, PRINCE OF WALES,
SOMEONE WOULD BE MISSED
ENORMOUSLY.
WE HEARD FROM THE OTHER CHILDREN
OF THE DUKE OF EDEN DOUGH ROW,
PRINCESS ANNE, PRINCE ED KWARD,
THAT WAS YESTERDAY.
TODAY WE ARE HEARING FROM THE
GRANDCHILDREN.
SO PRINCE WILLIAM WAS THE FIRST
TO COME OUT WITH A STATEMENT
FOLLOWED SHORTLY BY PRINCE
HARRY.
I'D LIKE TO READ YOU A PART OF
PRINCE WILLIAM'S STATEMENT, THE
DUKE OF CAMBRIDGE.
I FEEL LUCKY TO HAVE NOT JUST
HAD HIS EXAMPLE TO GUIDE ME, BUT
HIS ENDURING PRESENCE WELL INTO
MY OWN ADULT LIFE -- BOTH
THROUGH GOOD TIMES AND THE
HARDEST DAYS.
I WILL ALWAYS BE GRATEFUL THAT
MY WIFE HAD SO MANY YEARS TO GET
TO KNOW MY GRANDFATHER AND FOR
THE KINDNESS HE SHOWED HER.
AND PRINCE PARRY, HE WILL BE
REMEMBERED AS THE
LONGEST-REIGNING CONSORT TO THE
MON MARK, A DECORATED
SERVICEMAN, A PRINCE AND A DUKE.
OVER THE PAIN OF THIS PAST YEAR,
HE WAS MY GRANDFATHER, MASTER OF
THE BARBECUE, LEGEND OF BANTER
AND CHEEKY RIGHT TO THE END.
LINDA, WHAT WE ARE SEEING FROM
THE ROYAL FAMILY IS A MIX OF
THEIR OWN PERSONAL FEELINGS,
PERSONAL EMOTIONS AND ALSO HOW
THEY WANT HIM TO BE REMEMBERED
BY THE COUNTRY.
REMEMBER THIS IS NOT A FAMILY
THAT IS KNOWN FOR PUBLIC
DISPLAYS OF EFFUSIVE EMOTION.
SO THEY ARE CHOOSING THEIR WORDS
CAREFULLY.
THEY ARE GIVING US A RARE WINDOW
INTO HOW THEY FEEL IN ADDITION
TO THAT, THERE IS ALWAYS A
REFERENCE TO HIS LIFE OF
SERVICE, HIS GRANDSONS, IN
PARTICULAR, BOTH MENTIONED THIS
EXPRESSION OF GETTING THE JOB
DONE IN THEIR PUBLIC STATEMENTS
AND THAT IS NO ACCIDENT.
THAT IS, THEY REALLY ARE
CHANNELLING THE VOICE OF THE
LATE DUKE OF EDINBOROUGH, WHO IS
SOMEONE WHO DIDN'T LIKE A GREAT
FUSS OF THINGS.
WE ARE TOLD WOULDN'T WANT A BIG
FUSS MADE OF HIS OWN FUNERAL.
WHICH REMEMBER, IT WILL NOT BE A
STATE FUNERAL.
THAT IS RESERVED FOR MONARCHS.
SO THEY, THAT IS REALLY A POINT
THAT THE ROYAL FAMILY HAS BEEN
AT PAINS TO GET ACROSS TO THE
PUBLIC.
THAT THEY ARE CELEBRATING HIS
LIFE AND THEY ARE HONORING HIS
SERVICE.
HE WAS THE LONGEST-SERVING ROYAL
CONSORT, THE SPOUSE OF THE
MONARCH AND THAT MEANS, THAT HE
WAS THE PRIMARY AND MOST
STEADFAST SUPPORTER OF THIS
MONARCH YEARS OF THEELIZABETH A.
>> UNDER THE CURRENT COVID
RESTRICTIONS, WE KNOW THAT
ATTENDANCE AT FUNERALS IS
LIMITED TO 30 PEOPLE.
PRINCE PHILIP DID WANT A SMALL
SENDOFF, AS IT WERE.
>> Reporter: YEAH, HE DID,
INDEED.
THOSE PLANS HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED
FOR YEARS.
SO PRINCE PHILIP WOULD HAVE BEEN
A PART OF THE PLANNING FOR HIS
OWN FUNERAL DURING HIS LIFETIME.
HE APPROVED OF THE PLAN.
NOW, OF COURSE, THEY'RE HAVING
TO BE REVISED AND AMENDED TO
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT COVID PROTOCOL
SO WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THE
FUNERAL IS THAT IT IS GOING TO
TAKE PLACE SATURDAY AT 3:00 P.M.
BRITISH TIME AND IT IS GOING TO
START AT THE PRIVATE CHAPEL
WHERE THE BODY OF THE DUKE OF
EDINBOROUGH CURRENTLY RESTS.
HIS BODY WILL BE CARRIED OVER TO
WINDSOR CASTLE BEHIND ME.
IT WILL BE A SHORT PROCESSION
LINED BY REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
MILITARY ASSOCIATIONS TO WHICH
THE DUKE OF EDINBOROUGH HAD
TOUCH A STRONG ATTACHMENT.
REMEMBER, HE WAS A DECORATED
NAVAL OFFICER, HIMSELF, HE SAW
BATTLE IN THE SECOND WORLD WAR.
HIS COFFIN WILL BE CARRIED BY A
LAND ROVER, IT WILL BE A CUSTOM
BUILT LAND ROVER.
WE KNOW THE ROYAL FAMILY HAS
BEEN FOND OF THESE VEHICLES
SINCE THE 1940s.
THEN HIS COFFIN GETS TO
ST. GEORGE'S CHAPEL, IT WILL BE
RECEIVED BY THE ARCHBISHOP OF
CANTERBURY.
IT WILL BE A PRIVATE FUNERAL.
AFTER THAT PRIVATE FUNERAL, ONLY
30 PEOPLE ON THE GUEST LIST,
REMEMBER, BECAUSE OF COVID, THEN
HIS BODY WILL BE INTERRED IN THE
ROYAL VAULT AT WINDSOR CASTLE.
>> THANK YOU, SO MUCH.
WE WILL TALK AGAIN SOON.
>>> WELL, OVER THE YEARS, PRINCE
PHILIP WAS A PART OF THE ROYAL
FAMILY, SIGNIFICANT
INTERVENTIONS IN NORTHERN
IRELAND PEACE PROCESS.
THAT RECOGNITION COMING FROM THE
NORTHERN IRISH DEPUTY FIRST
MINISTER TODAY, A SPECIAL
MEETING.
IT COMES AS NORTHERN IRELAND
PULLS US TO HONOR PRINCE PHILIP
AFTER A RECENT FLARE-UP IN
VIOLENCE.
SELMA ABDEL AZEEZ REPORTS
WHETHER IT LASTS BEYOND THE
ROYAL FUNERAL SATURDAY.
>> Reporter: SUNDAY SERVICE FOR
AN ANXIOUS PROTESTANT COMMUNITY.
>> LEAD US IN PRAYER FOR PRINCE
PHILIP AND HIS FAMILY.
>> Reporter: HERE, THERE IS
MOURNING FOR PRINCE PHILIP AND
DEVOTION FOR THE QUEEN.
>> CAN I INVITE YOU TO STAND?
WE PAY TRIBUTE TO PRINCE PHILIP.
>> Reporter: AND PRAYERS FOR
PEACE, TOO.
>> WE CAN MOST CERTAINLY STAND
TOGETHER TO SAY VIOLENCE IS NOT
THE WAY.
>> Reporter: BELFAST WAS SHAKEN
BY VIOLENCE WHO HAVEN'T SEEN
SCENES HERE IN THE YEARS.
MOUNTING FRUSTRATIONS FROM
BREXIT LAWS TO COVID PRE 56 THES
POURED OUT ONTO THE STREETS.
THAT QUICKLY DEFENDED IN CLASHES
BETWEEN NORTHERN IRELAND,
BITTERLY DIVIDE, PROTESTANT AND
CATHOLIC COMMUNITIES.
BUT IN THE AFTERMATH OF PRINCE
PHILIP'S DEATH, CALLS TO END THE
FIGHTING BY PRO-BRITISH LOYALIST
LEADERS LIKE BILLY HUTCHINSON
WERE HEARD.
>> I FELT WE SHOULD RESPECT
PRINCE PHILIP.
WE DON'T WANT TO SEE PEOPLE OUT
IN THE STREETS.
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE WILL BE
VILIFIED.
>> Reporter: AT NIGHTFALL, WE
WITNESSED CALM IN BELFAST THIS
AREA IS OFTEN A FLASHPOINT.
ON THAT SIDE IS A PROTESTANT
COMMUNITY.
OVER THERE IS A CHECK
NEIGHBORHOOD.
AT TIMES THEY HAVE CLASHED HERE.
POLICE ARE TRYING TO KEEP THEM
APART.
BUT ALL POLITICAL PARTIES HAVE
CALL YOU CALLED ON EVERYONE TO
STAY HOME, STOP PROTESTING.
IT SEEMS TO BE WORKING.
AWAY FROM THE HOT SPOTS, THREE
NEWS WORKERS WHO TELL US THEY DO
NOT WANT TO RETURN TO THE HATRED
OF THE PAST.
YOU DON'T WANT TO BE INVOLVED IN
IT?
>> WHY NOT?
>> BECAUSE YOU'VE MOVED ON.
YOU WANT PEACE.
>> I THINK IT'S RECKLESS AND
DANGEROUS AND IT'S RECING THEIR
OWN COMMUNITY.
>> DOES ANY PART OF YOU FEEL
AFRAID?
FEEL LIKE, OH, THIS KICKS IT FOR
US?
>> YES.
THE FALLOUT IS TERRIBLE.
IT'S HARD TO GROW UP IN YOUR
SCURRY COMMUNITY.
>> Reporter: MOURNING FOR THE
FAMILY HAS QUIETED THESE
NEIGHBORHOODS, WHERE LOYALTY TO
THE MONARCH RUNS DEEP.
THE FE